[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'affronter fait son cinéma c'est une
programmation de six courts métrages
autour des fables
pour moi c'est important de le
programmer dans le cadre de ce festival
puisqu'il ya un réel moment des changes
entre les enfants et les parents
et bien souvent il s'agit de la première
première séance de cinéma pour les
enfants puisque c'est à partir de 3 ans
et il se retrouve dans une grande salle
obscure avec un immense écran et c'est
vrai que bien souvent le spectacle se
passe plus dans la salle qu'à l'écran
puisqu'ils sont pleins d'émotions et
c'est important que les parents soient
là déjà pour vivre ça et ensuite pour
pour comprendre expliquer si les enfants
n'ont pas compris tous les courts
métrages d'avoir toutes les clés pour
mieux comprendre
bien souvent on donne un écran aux
enfants et on les laisse seuls alors que
c'est très important d'accompagner les
enfants de leur expliquer ce qu'ils
regardent pourquoi
dans quel contexte
et
d'avoir toutes les explications puisque
les enfants n'ont pas forcément tous les
outils pour comprendre ce qu'ils
regardent les films c'est quelque chose
qui reste je pense que c'est important
au contraire dans un contexte actuel où
tout va trop vite ou on n'a pas le temps
de tout contrôler de se poser avec son
enfant de prendre le temps aussi de
découvrir des choses qui sont
différentes qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de voir à la télévision et 2
de vivre ces moments là à deux à trois
si l'on sait combien on est dans la
famille
[Musique]
ce qui m'inquiète
mais dit elle
alain tasma gaza
cl
pink est là qui sait